last Thursday I made a video saying that
space exploration in Starfield isn't
what people thought I made that video
based on a lot of questions I got where
people definitely missed information
from Bethesda people are asking me if
you can land on a planet or take off
from a planet and fly to another planet
the answer is no you cannot and myself
and seemingly quite a few other people
had incorrectly assumed that when you
land in space in Starfield before you
fast travel to a planet or open up your
scanner to drop you into the landing
animation on a planet that you were just
in a small Sky Box that would not move
you in any direction whatsoever you
would never get closer to a planet or
that you would eventually hit like an
out of bounds wall and you wouldn't be
able to go any further again both of
those things are incorrect but I ended
up not being a hundred percent sure and
wanted to test it so I did what any sane
person would do and spent seven hours
flying to Pluto now the reason I picked
Pluto despite it technically not being a
planet I know it is not functionally
going to act any differently in Star
Fields bethesda's not going to be like
well kudos not a planet let's design
that differently I chose Pluto because
when you drop in orbit around a planet
before you fast travel to it it was like
the shortest distance another part of
the reason that I chose Pluto instead of
choosing Earth was because Earth's orbit
was way too fast it was so difficult for
me to keep up with how fast Earth was
moving that was the first one that I
tried but Earth would just disappear
from view if I was flying straight super
quickly Pluto while it would still shift
in and out of frame in about an hour was
much much slower and thus much more
achievable I didn't have to stay awake
the entire time I finished actually
playing the game for a few hours and
then went to bed and left all field
running but there were hiccups several
of them several things that I found to
be unexpected challenges in getting to
Pluto slash seeing if we could get to
Pluto now it pretty quickly became
obvious that we were actually getting to
Pluto as Pluto was getting bigger so
that pot was proving to be worth it
Pluto was getting larger in the screen
bit by bit and the kilometer distance to
Pluto was slowly counting down and for
reference I was on the base ship with
one engine upgrade though based on what
happened when I actually got there I
don't imagine any ship is ever going to
be fast enough for you to frequently
travel between planets it is the game is
clearly not designed for you to actually
be able to do this it isn't actually
functional did we get to Pluto
technically yes did I really get to
Pluto
no you'll see but I don't imagine no
matter how fast your ship is or what
engine upgrades you get that this is
ever going to be a feasible part of the
game it is clearly not designed this way
but all planets in Starfield solar
systems have orbits which I think is so
unbelievably cool so the way I figured
this out is that as I was flying towards
Pluto for a certain amount of time
eventually the sphere that is Pluto even
though I was centered right in the
middle of the planet would shift out of
frame I think it started going like
bottom right and then ended up top left
and I was just so surprised they had
factored in orbits like what a cool
thing to discover despite it making this
process really annoying for me I
expected to be able to go to sleep and
set an alarm for seven hours later which
is like what I had figured it would take
it seemed like I think it was every 50
kilometers was about 15 minutes so I had
to set an alarm for every 30 minutes to
readjust my ship to make sure that we
wouldn't go way out of Pluto's orbit and
then accidentally overshoot it or like
head in the wrong direction which
actually did start happening at my one
point because of that setup because I
had to set an alarm for every 30 minutes
instead of just leaving my Xbox running
here in my office I took the controller
into my bedroom and put the stream on my
screen in my bedroom and so it was
occasionally waking up and adjusting it
with maximum latency because I was
watching the delay of the stream and
trying to readjust the ship it's like
clearly very weird movement because yeah
Not only was I not in the same room as
the Xbox I don't think that actually
would have caused much issue like I've
played in movie theaters before the Xbox
is like in the projection room that
doesn't seem to cause problems it was
the stream delay that caused the issue
so I was adjusting live on Twitch very
difficult every 30 minutes and
occasionally my controller would
disconnect even though I had it plugged
in which I guess was happening because I
was not connected to my Xbox I was
connected to a power outlet there was
one part where I slightly overslept and
I think the controller was disconnected
for like a good several minutes and
people were like panicking in the chat
it was one of the worst sleeps I've ever
had I didn't expect that to be part of
it also sorry if you can hear my dog
chewing up on in the back route but as
we got closer woke up in the morning
splash some water on my face ready to
face Pluto we finally actually got there
one of the wildest things about this is
that even while I was asleep streaming
nothing but space which by the way I was
also sleeping too right it is actually
really calming the only downside is that
I have one crewmate on my ship who would
occasionally cough other than that it's
very peaceful like 4 000 people watching
while I was asleep nuts so when we
actually got
to Pluto as we start to get closer and
the planet is at the point where it's
taking up the whole screen it's just
either white or it's black depending on
which way it is facing the sun which
again the whole orbit thing very very
very cool however it's extremely low
risk you are definitely not supposed to
be this close I mean why would anyone do
this in this game anyway it's insane and
there are a lot of people have different
opinions about like oh what it's
realistic what did you expect from space
travel versus like it's a video game so
you should be able to travel and it
should be fun I think I'm in the camp of
people of like the point of this game
especially now that I've played a lot
more of it is that it's an RPG and it's
about talking to people it's not really
a space exploration game and that's okay
but how you feel about that is how you
feel about that so we get that it the
resolution's terrible clearly not
designed for you to be this close and
then as I get very very close to the
surface like a few meters away you start
to see the headlights of the ship show
up on the planet so it's like a big
white light
oh
it was flat
Pluto confirmed flat flat Earth we just
went right through it
wait but it's still says zero hang on am
I inside Pluto
what happens if I turn around from here
I'm gonna turn around with my engines
off so I'm not actually moving
just to see
if there is any sign of Pluto behind me
we're inside of Pluto
we're definitely inside of Pluto
how long how long does it now take to
get out of Pluto
do I just live here now
so we have confirmed that things in
space off
physically where they say they are how
long will it take me to get anyone does
anyone know the diameter of Pluto how
long will it take me to get out Pluto is
literally the distance we travel to get
to Pluto I'm moving
or we can confirm that I'm moving if we
look at something else right is there
anything
but they're too far away
okay yeah see Sharon is moving
so I am moving inside Pluto
flying against the orbit will cut the
time down
I can't come into Pluto and not see what
it likes to looks like to get out of
Pluto
that wouldn't be upset and then no noise
no impact as cool as I think it would be
if they made you explode we actually
just clipped straight through the planet
and everything became invisible this is
not actually that uncommon in game
development to not have anything mapped
to the inside of a sphere but confirmed
it is a sphere it is not flat it is
probably a rotating sphere that is also
in orbit which again I think is like
super cool but you go inside the planet
and it says zero to Pluto and it said
that for as long as I flew I think I
threw flew maybe like another 15 minutes
in One Direction and didn't get any
further I didn't get out of Pluto
because it is just a big empty sphere
and it is big and I suspect perfectly to
scale with every other Hollow sphere of
a planet inside of the solar system and
this is how I imagine they have done
every single solar system what I don't
think you can do and I still don't know
because it would take you know I would
test it but it would take a thousand
hours ten thousand hours I don't think
you can fly between systems if Pluto is
the furthest out of the Soul system I
don't suspect that you can fly from
Seoul to another system that said it's
possible and the reason that I think
this is even possible is that having a
bunch of spheres that don't actually
have anything on them and are actually
very low resolution you're seeing them
from really far away is actually not
that intensive for a video game that's
actually not that difficult I mean there
are so many of them but really they're
just a bunch of images again I think the
orbits is what makes it a lot cooler but
it's not actually that hard to have a
whole bunch of these planets because
they're just not very resource intensive
so I don't suspect again that you can
fly between solar systems but you may be
able to uh I don't know that anyone will
achieve that without
um modding the second part of that is I
also still don't know if you can fly
from Pluto's orbit to another planet's
orbit so like I said we spawned outside
of Pluto intentionally and then flew
towards Pluto I don't know if you can
spawn outside of Pluto like fast travel
to outside of Pluto and then fly to the
next nearest planet or like fly to Earth
I don't know if there are separate
instances for these planets but I
suspect that it that you can I suspect
that you can get closer to each planet
and every individual solar system again
it's weird to call it a planet when
really it is a empty sphere
um and eventually we figured that it was
a sphere because I flew out of it so I
flew straight towards Pluto flew through
it and then hooked a left because I
figured because of the orbit of the
planet I would come out a little bit
faster if I went left than if I kept
going straight through because I mean
Pluto is like the distance that I
traveled to get to Pluto is the same
distance that the inside of Pluto would
have been so it would have taken another
seven hours to get out but yes I hooked
a left and eventually popped out of
Pluto and weirdly yeah Pluto like
started to like tuck under me because of
the orbit but the reason I think orbits
exist which again very cool was like
delighted to discover that here is so
that when you are standing on any of
these planets every other planet in the
solar system is accurately moving so
like if you're on a planet that doesn't
have light pollution whatever you can
see all of space you can see every other
planet they are actually moving around
in their correct patterns so the purpose
is not to visit these planets the
purpose is to when you're on a planet
see the other planets moving in space
that's why I think Todd Howard in one of
the presentations said see the moon it's
actually there well that is technically
correct the Moon is actually there and
that you could take off and fly to it
and clip through it it is an object that
exists in space within the solar system
with every other planet orbiting so no
clearly it is not designed for you to
actually visit planets there is no
Landing animation you can't fly to a
planet and then land on it like you can
in no man's Sky they did say that from
the start but you can get up very very
close and then eventually go inside of a
planet it is technically possible you
are moving through space the game is
just definitely not designed for you to
do that and honestly
one of the first things that I wanted to
try when even booting up Starfield was
flying into the sun just to see what
would happen I suspect the exact same
thing would happen that happened here
but the problem is the sun is so far
away if it took me seven hours to get
from Pluto's orbit to Pluto and you
can't spawn near the Sun at all I would
have to spawn in the orbit of the
nearest Planet I mean again A Thousand
Years it would take so long to get there
but thank you to everybody who joined me
on this fun journey of flying to Pluto
for seven hours straight just to confirm
for science if you are really moving in
space and what the objects in space
actually do I think an explosion
animation would have been really cool
and that's like maybe a a cool mod but
more than anything I I took away that
well very inconvenient for the purposes
of my experiment the fact that it orbits
is so neat